what up
hi friends
i'm back i you know
i was disinvited from the show i'm not
gonna say why but
will you just let's go
all right all right what's up what's
going on today so markets the markets
just markets grocery store markets or
other markets all sorts of markets all
right what's up declining but
i wanted to talk about this because i
thought what uh jim cramer said was
interesting he said that investors
shouldn't fear the markets declines now
that interest rates are coming down
since that means that there are more
buying opportunities and he said you
can't have it both ways you can't be
scared of higher rates and lower rates
history says we should like lower
interest rates and of course it's a sign
that the fed is winning its war against
inflation after a couple of aggressive
rate hikes what do we think about that
is this actually an opportunity for
investors did rates come down
are you asking me did rates come down
inc rates come down they will
eventually when the fed pivots and waves
the white flag and gives up
i think what his point take out the
interest rate conversation for a second
his point about if you like a company
well let's use equities as an example if
you like a company
and they continue to have pretty strong
performance but the valuation the market
cap of the business falls just means
it's cheaper
there's a whole generation
of people
who are learning
why value investors exist
what does warren buffett do
he sits there
and he just keeps collecting cash
collecting cash collecting cash
collecting cash
and then he waits
until there's moments of fear
prices are falling aggressively and then
he says let me put down my newspaper and
then he and i will
go and i will start to
buy equity no do the strike motion he
doesn't strike
he doesn't move with speed
he simply waits he's patient and then he
deploys his capital and so naturally
that's very hard to do it takes
discipline it means you have to resist
fomo
when prices are going up but if you look
at it he's sitting with a record level
of cash and he's starting to deploy now
even though that is true he still has
underperformed something like bitcoin
because there are multiple ways to
invest capital so if
you like to
buy things for cheaper than they're
worth then you are likely to become a
value investor and you wait for moments
like this and you have a field day
they're dancing on graves they're
running around saying value investing is
not dead look at how great we are
at the same time there's a lot of people
who say well i actually want to be a
technology investor i want to be an
innovation expert a way to think about
this is the technology investor bets on
the world changing warren buffett and
the value investors many times bet on
the world not changing
depends on the personality depends on
what you find interesting depends on how
data driven you are versus intuition
driven whatever
and so i think that's what jim cramer's
talking about here is if prices come
down and there's still good companies
then they're just cheaper
and if you like the company and it's
cheaper then you should like it more
because it's at a lower price it's like
going to the store and saying man i want
to buy that pair of shoes when it was a
hundred dollars i liked them now if
they're on a 50 off sale yep like more
why are they 50 off
that is what you should wonder is it out
of style you should ask yourself who
by the way seasons and style is complete
[ __ ]
like the whole fashion world the like oh
we have like fall fashion like no you
don't
y'all are just trying to move inventory
so you can get higher sales tell the
people the fashion sense doesn't change
between summer and fall
tell the people what you wore
from
2016 to 2018.
what i wear on your feet
what did i wear
you just want me to say it yeah the
questions
the reebok
questions
if you're if you're in your like early
to mid 30s
you know moving on let's move on because
i want to get to allen iverson question
single greatest shoe ever made fashion
statement but also
usable enough in case you need to go
dunk on somebody maybe you need to run
somewhere maybe you need to
kick somebody in the shins he fake
played basketball on the streets of new
york city to cross an old lady crossing
the street no she she was trying to mess
with me first i was like yeah we were
like you know kind of like joking around
or whatever and then she like started
getting like i was like oh you really
going to try to cross me up and i was
like all right well like let me just get
you know
go ahead what's going on
okay speaking of new york city manhattan
apartment sales
are falling they have fallen 30 percent
but
the prices still remain really high
why are why is that why are the prices
not catching up with the lack of demand
well they fell thirty percent the sale
june is that year over year or from
uh may
does it say
um it is it's the big branch of course
yeah yeah year over year june 2021 yeah
so likely what happened was in june of
2020 no one was buying anything because
everyone was scared of the covid stuff
everyone's moving out of new york prices
were falling it was all mass chaos then
by the time we got to june of 2021 they
had already started all the quantitative
easing they were driving a ton of uh
cheap capital into the market people
were starting to realize hey maybe i
should go buy some real estate they were
borrowing capital to go purchase these
things sales exploded all from summer of
last year into the second half of the
year and then
now
interest rates have grown aggressively
mortgage rates are like double what they
were just back in january and february
and so what do people do
they aren't going to buy as much anymore
and so like it makes sense that the
demand for cheap cap or the demand for
sales uh
has fallen demand for apartments have
fallen but the prices
they take a little bit and so my
expectation is if we are seeing a 30
drawdown year-over-year in apartment
sales in new york give it a couple of
months and you'll see prices start to
fall as well
price is sensitive to changes in demand
but it is not so sensitive that it
changes on a day-to-day basis yeah right
what you're gonna have to wait for is
you're gonna have to wait for the market
to internalize yes demand has changed
and then you'll see the prices start to
fall but i really don't have shoulders
okay what's up with rihanna
is now worth 1.4 billion dollars making
her america's youngest self-made
billionaire woman
she's 34 she owns half of fenty beauty
and the other half is owned by french
luxury fashion conglomerate lvmh
i have written about lvmh before
that is that fashion powerhouse where
the ceo of it is this man named bernard
arno
and he's pretty much always like neck
and neck with jeff bezos on who's the
richest person on the planet he's worth
199 million dollars and if i can say i
think one of rihanna's geniuses is that
she sold part of that company to um yes
that helped yes that definitely helped i
think that rihanna's worth more than 1.4
billion though okay well that's pennies
my guess is that the 1.4 billion is
almost exclusively based on her stake
and she probably actually made way more
money than we realize on other
endeavors including as a musician or
whatever well they do account for some
of her music career that you know
contributes but
her she has three retail companies fenty
beauty fenty skin and savage by fenty
wow so she's an entrepreneur who does
music do we think that rihanna has just
like surrounded herself with really
really intelligent people or do we think
it's her doing these deals knowing
what's going on striking things here and
there i think i think that people
drastically underestimate the type of
person it takes
to become highly successful as a
musician
uh if you look there's a
it's not a new documentary but it just
came out on netflix uh can't stop own
stop it's all about puff daddy p diddy
or diddy depending on what generation
what depending on what generation uh you
interacted with the man the legend
oh yeah when we were younger yeah he was
puff daddy then he went to p diddy p
diddy was the name that came from uh
notorious b.i.g
uh and then
after that he just became diddy that's
how you know you're mature and you just
go diddy just drop the p uh if you go
ahead and you take a look at that
documentary it's very clear like
you know i don't want to ruin it for
everyone but when he first starts he
works at a label and he is so
hungry so i'm gonna do things my way
that at one point he gets fired from the
label because he takes his shirt off in
the office and he punches somebody in
the face the general manager
and like i'm sure now
he's probably like i wasn't the smartest
thing i was young i was immature
whatever but like
that is a different type of person
and then goes on and basically every
single artist he touches uh in his
career and has a hand in their uh kind
of rise becomes hyper successful i think
rihanna's very similar in that it seems
like every time she touches a business
it ends up being successful and so
there's this element of yes it takes a
special type of person to be able to do
this
and really it comes down to like she's
an entrepreneur yes she had the music
career but she is an entrepreneur i mean
i mean cardi b
yeah shout out cardi b he loves cardi b
i love cardi b after i watched uh she
did the sit down with david letterman
yeah and uh in it she's she's savage
sorry just really quick to interject the
people in the comments are saying he was
also known as puffy at one point don't
forget puffy
okay ready
are we moving on
uh guys got so many nicknames you can't
keep track of them all but i think
that's cool that she is
i think rihanna is going to be known as
an entrepreneur more so than she is as
an artist in the future i think so i
don't know because even if you look at
somebody like shaquille o'neal or magic
johnson i guess i think a lot of people
know yes they are good at business good
at business whatever that ultimately
means but i still think that if you go
and you ask folks shaq is known as an
nba player
right magic johnson what i think he was
like the general manager or whatever the
los angeles lakers he was uh uh a
co-owner of the los angeles dodgers uh
he has all of these franchises like all
this stuff that he's done
still he's a basketball player but do
you think it's different because people
are buying her products michael jordan
yeah yeah is he a entrepreneur or a
basketball player well but that's kind
of it's different because he was already
a legend like i mean ryan
she is but name two rihanna songs uh
umbrella and uh
i'm bad at song name legend
no she did all i know all of her songs i
could sing all of her songs sorry you
want to know who's on duration i see
people talking about you know who you
wanna know who's an underrated
entrepreneur
what
50 cent curtis jackson
curtis jackson made a bag
selling y'all water you just learned
made a bag yeah made a bag that's what
the kids told me made a bag
selling
water
to you fools with different colors in it
vitamin water supposedly that was his
idea
he supposedly he claims this is his
claim i saw a video an interview diamond
in the sky thank you he went
and he was at the store and he realized
that one water bottle was being sold for
a dollar 25 and another was being sold
for like 25 cents or whatever the
numbers were like 250 and 75 cents or
whatever and he was like
damn poland springs out here got you all
convinced to pay like six times more for
their water over the other water so he
went back and he told his team he said
i want to sell water and at first they
were like what do you mean you want to
sell water he goes i want to get in the
water game and so they ended up doing uh
vitamin water and it's unclear whether
they actually started vitamin water or
if they just inve they found a team and
they invested in it but the company was
sold for over four billion dollars if i
remember correctly and in that four
billion dollar sale he made hundreds of
millions of dollars on it
wow
he also
has a tv show he also has a tv show on
stars uh power i think it's called
where he he was a character in the show
and then he killed himself off the show
and people have asked him about it and
he said all y'all thought that i was
dumb for killing myself off it's called
making a business y'all go do the
recording and i get paid
entrepreneur great
okay you want another one nope all right
what's up with amazon amazon on
wednesday agreed to take a stake in
grubhub
it's part of a deal that will also give
members of amazon prime subscription
program a one-year membership to the
food delivery service the partnership
gives amazon option take a two percent
stake in grubhub grubhub which is the
u.s subsidiary of just the takeaway.com
which is the european food giant do you
remember my little cousin in bulgaria
works for a takeaway remember i remember
yeah his customer service if y'all are
complaining you might be talking to him
i'll be complaining to him uh what do
you think about this um so i think i
think this is incredibly smart
why because amazon i mean they can do
all sorts of things with uh
food delivery and i'm actually surprised
they haven't dipped their toe in just
yet
should amazon buy something like go puff
probably
but isn't gopa valued at like a
bajillion dollars
jeff bezos could buy it personally and i
even realized the money's gone that's
also true even if it was 25 billion
dollars he'd be like what uh yeah i
think that was a rounding error but yeah
so guys got more cash than anyone other
than vladimir putin amazon has this like
captive audience right they have the
amazon prime members and there's 200
million plus members wow what's up with
gorgeous
gorgosaurus
this looks like some dinosaur [ __ ] so
remember when you wanted to buy a
dinosaur skeleton and put it in our
kitchen in new york city
ladies and gentlemen just in case y'all
don't know
there's this thing i didn't know this
was a thing until i was hanging out with
one of my friends who i call him a
friend but he's you know up here in life
i'm like well actually i'm down here
like underneath the table and uh
i was talking to him and all of a sudden
he started talking about dinosaurs now i
wish you mean dinosaurs he's like yeah i
got a dinosaur oh
like a real one and he was like nah like
i like got the fossils like all stuff
and i went down this rabbit hole i went
home i was googling uh what are you rich
people doing well and then all these
guys
buddies rich people they got dinosaur
fossils so then i started saying well if
that's what rich people do then maybe i
need to get some dinosaur fossils i'll
bring it you know bring it to the people
and then i looked at the price tags and
i'm gonna just look at the pictures
online because those are pretty damn
expensive the gorgosaurus it roamed the
earth approximately 77 million years ago
predating the t-rex it's close relative
by around 10 million
so
5 million so they're selling it for it
could sell for more than 5 million
but
that whole thing that's the picture of
it yeah the gorgosaurus skeleton being
offered for sale was discovered in 2018.
yeah could we do it in the studio could
we put it here yeah they they really
don't mess with me right now two feet
long no don't play with me right now
that that's the real picture of it and
it's five million dollars yep man i bet
you i can find some people who'll be
putting some cash in on that no but i
think i think it's gonna be awesome can
you leave it outside it's gonna be
auctioned on july 28th so technically it
could sell for even
more oh they think it'll go for five
million ah come on inflation's eight
point six percent that bad boy going for
ten for sure bad bad boy yeah come on
look at that thing just looks
cool yeah the fact that they have so
many of its bones right well that's
because they probably found the fossils
right but sometimes they they'll find
like one tiny little bones like this you
think that you think right there uh the
mouth is open or closed anthony nothing
will eat you alive without even if i was
around with the dinosaurs they'd be my
friend no way
100 you could be running
no 100 percent they would be like
renting across them i'd have pet
dinosaurs i'd be like all right listen
this is how it's going to work ready
y'all don't have to go looking for food
i'll go find the food y'all just be
keeping the other dinosaurs all right
well that's it for lunch money
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time